Hello.
Thank you for calling Grand Hotel.
My name is Laurie.
How can I help you?
Hello.
A couple of weeks ago, I made a reservation and I have to cancel my reservation.
Absolutely.
Let me bring you up on the system here.
Do you have the reservation number?
Reservation number?
Yeah, you received that when you called the first time.
No, I haven't.
I haven't received any.
Oh, that's not a problem.
I can look you up on the system.
What's the last name on the reservation?
Yes!
My last name is Veltman.
V E L T M A N.
And what's your arrival date?
October 12th.
Okay, let me see here.
Here you are!
And you'd like me to cancel that reservation?
I need to cancel the reservation, yes.
No problem at all, sir.
I just need the credit card number that you used to make the reservation with.
Okay.
My credit card number is 12345678900.
Okay, I can cancel your reservation right now.
Thanks.